let's create a weather provider class
within the data package will have an
extend content provider you can add the
required methods by hitting ctrl I once
more content providers implement
functionality based upon you our eyes
each URI type is tied to an integer
constant our content provider will
implement five different types of you
our eyes each one of these URIs will be
used for different types of queries for
now let's just add these constants into
our weather provider class Android
provides a URI matcher class to help
match your eyes to our integer constants
it provides for an expression syntax to
match various your eyes now these are
just examples you're going to have to
implement one of these very soon note
that there are two wildcards the pound
sign is used to match a number while a
star is used to match a string using
this you can very very easily match any
of the URIs that we would want to pass
in to our content provider